developer Niantic labs has published a
blog post explaining why it shut down
various Pokemon go tracking sites I'm
Dave and welcome to your where the hell
is that porygon GS news update the post
comes less than a week after third-party
tracking apps including the popular
pokévision was shut down as detailed on
my antics official Pokemon go website
blocking the third parties who are
accessing Niantic servers freed up a
significant amount of resources some of
which helped the developer to proceed
with his recent launch of the game in
Latin America the post read we wanted to
shed some more light on why we did this
and why these seemingly innocuous sites
and apps actually hurt our ability to
deliver the game to new and existing
players in addition the developer shared
a chart which display the drop in server
resources consumed after the third-party
scrapers were blocked 90 also explained
the developers who spend their time
dealing with these issues have their
time taken away from building new
features for the game the post
acknowledges other issues including
users cheating and attempts to break
into the system but states that the
developer will continue to take steps to
maintaining the stability and integrity
of the games so is losing the ability to
track Pokemon a little easy a
deal-breaker for you or are you still
working on being the very best let us
know in the comments section below of 5
million twitter at irregular dave and
for the pokemon news make sure you
subscribe to GameSpot